Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Anxiety: Lost Night.
Now my voice isn't still 100% correct but it's good enough to start recording.
I've got a whole slew of indie horror games for you guys to explore.
And we're back in the old recording room. The place where it all began.
Well, I mean not this room specifically. I started out in my mom's basement just downstairs but uh...
I moved up to this room and then...then started making videos. But this is Anxiety: Lost Night
And there was a game that came before it...called Anxiety.
That I believe was another horror game that's like this kind of 2-D style.
"Everything is going to be alright. Just need to calm down and drive."
"It's okay, just a little bit more. What? No, not again, not now!"
Okay....so in this one..."Shit! Come on!"
In this one... I believe you're trapped in a car. And death, lurks around every corner.
Oh!
I am legitimately trapped in a car- Why am I sitting in the middle?
Why am I in the absolute middle of this?
"It's dark outside" Yeah, I am aware of that!
*car honks* Oh, that's not a good thing!
*car honks* HEY! *honk* HEY *honk* ALL YOU MONSTERS *honk*! I'M *honk* HERE! *honk*
Okay, "there should be a bus station-" oh, boy.
Hiiii...Sorry about all the honking!
"I need a map."
*honks* I NEED A MAP!!
Well, that didn't work. uh ok.
Alright, it looks like uh- "There's one not far from here" *noise of discomfort*
Yooh National Parks, bring nature to your soul..."I should be able to walk there"
*chuckling* "I have to go outside..."
*noise of discomfort*
That's probably a bad- *suspenseful noise* Heeeeey.
OH, it's the monster I summoned with my honking!
"A cougar?"  *mockingly* Oh no, a cougar is out there.
Alrighty then..*honks*
Hey! *honk x2* Hey cougar!
Oh boy, that's not good.
oh no
*laughing* Noooo
Oh, I've done goofed haven't I
Okay.. Boop!
Hello..."I need the key" ooop, oh shit, fucked that one up!
Oh, fuck!
Huhhhh did it!
Alright, so that's not working.
"I didn't save his number" Whose number are you talking about here?
"I should have his business card somewhere" Who you talkin' about?
hi
okay...
just hang on...
Hang on a second
"Why do I keep this?" eugh
Alright, so there maybe a piece of the puzzle missing from the first game. I might go back and play that later.
So I- *noise of discomfort*
Well, these are, these are not reassuring noises.
So, "he gave me a business card."
*noise of discomfort*
Somewhere...
GR. Garage Autoworks...Okay
So, I got his number!
"Garage here. Sorry, we're about to close soon" WAIT I'M ABOUT TO DIE. "IT'S ME"
Don't you recognize my voice?!
"Oh, ma'am what's wrong?"
Uhhh...death? Lurks around the corner?
"Car won't start, need your help please" pretty please
"Hear you....Signal...bad....Where are you, Ma'am?"
...I dunno
"North route of the national park." Ya know, where all the DEMONS are!
They're gonna come and kill me
"What....you doing there....at this time?"
Oh fuccck.
"Just shut up and help me...please"
That would be lovely "I'll be there in an hour"
AN HOUR?!
I'M GONNA BE DEAD IN AN HOUR
I CAN'T STOP HONKING MY HORN
"I can't wait that long, just walk me through it, what should I do?"
"Alright....try....turn off all the electronics on your car...."
Okayyy...."It worked last time, right?" I don't remember!
Yeesh
Alrighty then
Okay! Gonna do that.
"He gave me a note...where is it?" A note?! What do you mean, a note?!
Put it in my bag?
Uh, eh, doh
Okay..."God, I..." *chuckling* "I looks awful." Lisa Mattison...alrighty then
K. "I don't remember" Why did I leave this- OH GOD WHY DO I HAVE THAT
Why do I have that?
Alright, got a key.
"It's okay, it's okay"
Alright....Am I gonna die?
OH HI
OH FUCKING FUCK
AHHH, YOU BITCH
YA BITCH
*honking* Fuck you! Fuck you! Fuck all y'all!
Oh boy...
Man, my voice is not gonna survive this.
Hi...Hello! Okay!
Oh boy.
"Turn off air conditioner, every light in car, wiper, unplug your radio power cable, processing...pressing the horn also makes it worse."
Oops!
My bad!
Okay...
"Remember don't turn all the devices in one time Make sure all electronic devices are off when you start the ignition."
Okay....
Alrighty then..
*Honks* MEEP!
*honks twice* MEEP! MEEP!
*spooky noises*
Okay sorry! Shouldn't meep! I get it! No meepin'!
*noise of discomfort*
"I don't need this anymore"
Oh...
I'm gonna be like Fran Bow...
Okay, so
Take this-why is it bloody? Why is everything I own bloody?
And why is there a normal garage guy going about his business? Alright...
Shoop-a-doop-boop-a-doop
Boink!
Got that...
Turn off the lights...
Nnnnnnn doot
*car clicks*
Alright, doot-ed that.
Doot-ed that. Didn't know it was so complex to turn off my god damn stuff.
Hep-boop doot-ed that
Okay...
Alright *CLANG*
FUCKING FUCK
THAT'S NOT WHAT I WANTED
*noise of discomfort*
Alright!
Errybody calm down here!
Alright, I need to turn off....
No, not that!
God dammit!
Okay, is everything off?!
Ah, fuck!
*honk* HAH
K, here we go
*car sputters*
FECK
K, so I gotta somehow- *CLANG*
FUCKING STOP
OKAY?!
*spooky sound*
ENOUGH!
*honks* FUCK OFF
Alright, so I gotta turn off...
Oh, maybe-maybe that got turned on again
HEYO-HI
OH OKAY
Well that's, that's not supposed to be on
Okay, let's-let's try this.
*car sputters*
I followed the instructions!
Okay *sniffle*
Unplug, pressing horn makes it worse, lights on -OH
My, oh I know what's up, my
These are on!
*car clicks*
Ahhh, there we go. Okay.
Bam.
Hi. Stop that please.
Can I just turn on the GODDAMN CAR GO AWAY
*noise of extreme discomfort*
*sound of a confused cow?*
Okay, I don't wanna
Okay, alright then
*car sputters*
Goddammit, how did these get turned on
*car clicks*
*car sputters*
I fucking...god-
*noise of discomfort*
Alrighty then...
Alright, I get it. I get it. I get it.
There's some kind of..
There's some electronic- oh what the fuck?
*car clicks*
*clang*
Man these- *noise of discomfort*
Fuck off!
I get it! I get it! I get it! Stop!
*car clicks*
You trying to do me a great goofage
Hello! I know! I get it.
Fuck *car click*
STOP
AYE FUCKIN'
WHAT!?
NO!
FUCK YOU!!
Oh, fuck off!
God dammit.
I was that close!
Ah, it fucked me!
It fucked me!
*crinkling and noise of discomfort*
Oh...okay
Alright...that's
That's nice
That's real nice
*noise of discomfort*
Alrighty then
*car clicks*
At least we got no attacker on the way.
I probably spoke too soon but whatever.
*car clicks*
*car sputter but starts*
YAY?!
"It's not my fault"
I was that close to winning and then I died....
"It's not my fault. I deserve a better life"
I dunno! You got a bloody rope! You got a bloody screwdriver!
You got alotta *tries to pronounce medicine name*
Yeesh, shit
I dunno...
I don't know what's exactly what's coming-
*screams and spooks*
Fucking hell!
*tires screeching* What was that?
*car crashes*
Okay?!
*noise of discomfort* Oh boy!
That was the end?
Oh, okay
*giggles*
Alright, so that was Anxiety: Lost Night
Pretty good start to the slew of horror games but I've got a big list!
I've got like 30 games to get through but my voice may not keep up through it all
But I will try my best to get you all the horror games you could possibly imagine along with some old favorites!
I've got Subnautica coming at you real soon.
So thank you everybody so much for watching. And as always, I will see you in the next video!
Buh bye!